megan is with us in texas welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Megan are you better
than I deserve what's up so I need some
wisdom we are currently in baby foot two
we have already paid off 20,000 but we
still have 36,000 to pay off that
includes a fifteen hundred dollar
medical bill a car loan 13,000 and a
truck loan for 22,000 our household
income is 110,000 in our issue that we
help prioritizing and staying on track
with the baby set and especially with
some issues there on the horizon and we
have known for a couple years that our
foundation is getting to be repaired but
we've been putting it on the back burner
and now we're noticing there's some
cracks in the ceiling and things like
that so we're thinking it needs to be
addressed sooner than later and then our
roots are 16 years old and it probably
needs repaired soon and then there's
other things like our kitchen isn't mean
to be updated and our house is falling
apart and we just need to know how do we
prioritize and address these issues
appropriately but then still stay on
track okay and also dad I don't hear
anything there that you're going to fix
until you're out of debt okay because
then you're gonna have the money to fix
them yeah the house is not falling in
it's got a crack in the living room
ceiling most houses do it's been this
way he's been working on this for five
years you should be out of debt in two
years or less and if you can't be true
you may need to sell the truck to get
out of that this year
good you can pay off all that that you
outlined in one year we are I mean if we
cut everything that we can and I mean it
really because they'll intense
good good so this time next year you're
fixing the first repair that's the
highest priority okay that's cool just
put everything on the back burner then
there's nothing on fire
there's nothing you outline they can't
wait a year a kitchen remodel can wait
five years I don't want to because I
hate a stinky bad old ugly kitchen but
but it's that's a luxury upgrade a house
it's got some settling issues unless
it's got something that's dramatic we'll
wait a year okay I guess in my mind I
wasn't thinking well if we wait you know
there's gonna be more cracks and then
we're gonna have to do more repairs it
might cost you an extra $500,000 as
possible
whoopee okay you make a hundred and ten
thousand dollars and you've been broke
your whole married life it's time to
change yeah you've been buying stupid
cars you couldn't afford on payments
long enough you have to break the back
of this thing you know and you're in the
process of doing it it's just scary and
it feels like it's gonna be longer than
it is I mean think about what you're
doing this time last year
I mean you snap your fingers here we sit
a year later right a year goes so crazy
yeah and so you're gonna be you're gonna
be working on the most important thing
and I think the most important thing in
what you outline might be unless the
roof is in worse shape than you
described it might be the settling might
need to be fixed first and then you
would fix the roof those are more
necessities upgrading the kitchen would
probably be your third but you just
start laying out just like you did with
your baby steps you start laying out an
order a priority and you save up and fix
that one
save up fix that one save up fix that
one okay you follow the plan follow the
plan well it is it's just what happens
is you're looking at that stuff and your
emotions are telling you you're never
gonna do it but when you and I lay out
when I warn you and I lay it out
intellectually you're saying we're gonna
be done in a year and if you think
that's not up fast enough you can sell
the truck and that would cut half of
your time off you know so are you
panicked enough
the settling to do the settling fix six
months sooner if you are sell the truck
are you that panicked I'm I'm not but if
you are no man do what not at this
moment but I like it you know there's
more cracks and things like that and I
might be a little more you know well I
mean so by summer you got everything
paid off but the truck right cuz this
your last big one wasn't it correct yeah
so if you get down to that and that's
the last thing and the thing the house
starts shifting and you know you start
freaking out sell the truck you're
debt-free then you can start in twenty
minutes making your kind of money you'll
have the money saved it to fix the
foundation and the cracks but if you can
wait long enough to get the truck paid
off and keep it then you're probably
sitting at this time next year with the
numbers you gave me and that's what you
said your else plan was so I think
you're okay I think you're okay but
you're right you have to cut down to
beans and rice rice and beans and you're
not going on vacation this year and
you're not gonna be seeing inside a
restaurant unless you're working there
and you know you so much stuff's up for
sale the kids think they're next and all
that stuff right gazelle intensity we're
game on right game on and you got some
real motivation to do that because you
want to get out of debt so that your
first so that you can do these home
repairs you're next so that might be you
retire with dignity or you find your
kids college you find your next so that
might be that we change our family tree
your next so that might be that I want
to give away a million dollars it's not
just having million dollars you know you
can change your so that's your why as
you go along right now though you got a
pretty good why they you got cracks no
ceiling I don't get your butt in gear
and and keep you can sell intense and
keep you focused and anytime somebody
wants to do something you you you know
you just look at them and go no you know
and that's that then we can stop that
right we're good with it do you see the
cracks in the ceiling no we're not doing
that we got to get out of debt so we can
fix this stupid house and once you get
that stuff dialed in then you know what
you've got to do to do it then it's easy
to keep everybody else you don't in tow
and on track you're doing good you're
doing better than you feel like you're
doing